[Applauso]
[Musica]
Buongiorno a tutti il tema è molto molto
interessante quando mi è stato proposto
di mettere raccogliere le idee per
parlare di equilibrio per me che vengo
da un programma
storico della tv italiana un programma
di cui si parla molto spesso che fa
parlare di sé molto spesso e che è fatto
da una varietà di artisti non solo
giornalisti che Prova a dare un
a contribuire al racconto della società
italiana
l'ho sempre immaginato come un vero
punto di equilibrio per un Marziano che
decidesse di scegliere l'Italia come
luogo nel quale atterrare e chiedersi ma
come è fatto questo paese
cosa pensano le persone che lo vivono
Quali sono i pregi della sua popolazione
quali i difetti
certo immaginare
un'idea di equilibrio
applicato al mondo dell'informazione su
quella che è sulla base della mia
esperienza
professionale rischia di farci
inciampare e di cadere in un equivoco
Che cos'è l'equilibrio tutti vogliamo
un'informazione equilibrata spesso viene
frainteso l'equilibrio con
l'equilistanza e viviamo un'epoca di
Sfide estremamente complesse per il
mondo dell'informazione perché nella
nostra società è aumentata a dismisura
in ciascuno di noi la voglia di
precisione di accuratezza di
affidabilità
e si pretende dal dagli operatori del
mondo dell'informazione la stessa
precisione che ci si aspetta in una sala
operatoria dove c'è un cardio un
neurochirurgo
tassi di accuratezza tassi di mortalità
sotto l'uno per cento su migliaia e
migliaia di interventi
ma D'altro canto abbiamo visto che in
questi anni è stata messa molto in
discussione sia la formula di equilibrio
intesa come elaborazione di un racconto
affidabile sul quale fare affidamento ma
anche è la stessa nozione di
equidistanza che per alcuni aspetti
dell'equilibrio è un riflesso e vorrei
approfittare per fare una riflessione
con questa platea che è una platea
giovane una platea curiosa e una platea
Vitale Come si fa a mantenere
l'equilibrio quando da una parte c'è
qualcuno
che vorrebbe farvi credere che
attraverso l'iniezione di una di un
vaccino qualcuno vi stia impiantando un
microchip Ovviamente sto brutalizzando e
quando dall'altra parte c'è il consenso
della comunità scientifica che dice che
quella è una sciocchezza
è possibile oscillare tra questi due
aspetti tra questi due punti di vista
che sono assolutamente inconciliabili la
risposta è no Quindi che cos'è
l'equilibrio in questo caso e dare lo
stesso spazio è la stessa voce è la
stessa dignità narrativa di
partecipazione al dibattito a chi dice
che due per due fa cinque
assieme a chi dice che due per due fa
quattro che invece dovrebbe essere
l'unica parte ammessa in quel tipo di
discussione provate ad applicare questa
questa ricerca dell'equilibrio a molti
campi quello scientifico è molto facile
È molto facile da
raffigurare È molto facile per noi
immaginare Quali sono gli effetti quali
sono in che modo difendersi dal rischio
di essere spostati da quello che l'asse
del vero
l'asse del vero
i giornalisti dovrebbero impegnarsi a
raccontare la verità è una cosa che io
ho sempre sentito dire non vengo dalla
scuola di giornalismo studiato
giurisprudenza ma ho sempre immaginato
l'ambizione della non della ricerca
della verità
trovare la verità un'ambizione talmente
alta per un giornalista che si
impegnasse Al massimo delle sue capacità
e sfrutti ogni minuto della sua vita
studiare in profondità le storie che
racconta un po' come la pretesa che è un
buon cattolico che va in chiesa tutte le
domeniche che rispetta tutti i precetti
dei suoi insegnamenti potesse in qualche
modo ambire alla Santità cioè una
distanza enorme
ecco
Provate a cercare l'equilibrio quando
non si tratta più di dire che 9,81 metri
al secondo e la velocità della
alla quale un corpo viene attirato verso
il centro della terra la forza di
gravità e provate ad applicare questo
tema a un
argomento che in questi cinque anni alle
Iene ho affrontato in diverse chiavi e
in diverse storie
che è quello della Giustizia
cioè quando non è più una scienza esatta
ma quando è una scienza sociale è il
diritto è scienza sociale pratica almeno
questo è quello che mi hanno insegnato e
trovo che sia una definizione è molto
azzeccata è necessario che tutti tutti
dove si tratta di giustizia debbano
poter partecipare al dibattito è vero
che tutti hanno il diritto di sapere
come viene amministrata La giustizia è
vero che tutti noi abbiamo bisogno di un
equilibrio Che cosa c'è di più
equilibrato di una storia
che è stata sottoposta all'accertamento
della verità attraverso i mezzi che sono
quelli del giudizio di cognizione civile
ma io mi sono appassionato sono
appassionato ancora di più di quello
penale No quello è un punto di
equilibrio c'erano delle parti in causa
più parti in causa eventualmente e si è
trovata una sintesi il frutto di quella
sintesi è la cosa giudicata la sentenza
definitiva
ai giornalisti capita spesso di
oscillare come sto facendo anch'io
perché sono emozionato Davanti a questa
platea e quindi oscillo per stemperare
di oscillare tra due momenti la storia
che accende la curiosità di tutti perché
ci sono le indagini preliminari e tutti
vogliono sapere chi è il colpevole
magari di un fatto
gravemente
molto violento
e ai giornalisti viene detta una cosa
che io condivido i processi si fanno in
tribunale i processi non si fanno in un
salotto TV i processi non si fanno sulle
colonne di un giornale vero
e allora mi sono cimentato
nell'aspettare che il tribunale abbia
svolto il suo accertamento Che cos'è il
processo penale è un modo di
accertamento della verità un modo un
modo governato da regole che sono
potremmo chiamare regole di esclusione
cioè noi stabiliamo prima cosa
all'interno del processo non deve
entrare l'inchiesta giornalistica
Potremmo definirla l'opposto è un
meccanismo regolato da regole di
inclusione cerchiamo di allargare il
cerchio lo spazio degli elementi che
sono ammessi nel racconto che sono che
hanno la dignità di essere portati
All'attenzione del pubblico bene
bene in questa ricerca di equilibrio è
capitato spesso di sentirmi dire Eh ma
se il tribunale ha parlato perché ve ne
state occupando lo sappiamo già come è
andata a finire quella storia quel caso
E allora dove sta l'equilibrio ma
soprattutto il nostro mestiere quando lo
facciamo in che cosa potremmo riassumere
il concetto di
giornalismo Oggi viviamo in una società
dove la comunicazione è prevalente sul
giornalismo
ed è prevalente una comunicazione che è
ossessionata dall'idea del consenso cioè
dall'idea di raccogliere il maggior
numero possibile di like il maggior
numero possibile di commenti aumentare
l'engagement rate il giornalismo invece
si incarica di fare tutt'altro mettervi
davanti a uno specchio oppure
raccontarvi qualcosa che sicuramente fa
vacillare le vostre certezze che vi che
l'equilibrio che è stato in qualche modo
afferrato ve lo sottrae e davanti a
questa sottrazione possiamo reagire in
due modi possiamo
ribellarci a questo furto e protestare
Oppure possiamo accendere la nostra
curiosità allenare il muscolo dello
stupore e provare a essere pubblico
attivo cittadini attivi a farsi
incuriosire verificare se ciò che
abbiamo ascoltato è vero oppure no
dico che è molto
è molto entusiasmante l'idea che il
nostro racconto debba essere equilibrato
ma l'equilibrio non può mai essere
l'equilistanza tra ciò che i nostri
occhi hanno visto e ciò che qualcun
altro ha stabilito che dobbiamo vedere
questo riflesso nell'ambito della
nell'ambito della Giustizia ha delle
grandi implicazioni perché il
giornalismo è l'unico potere che
consente a al cittadino comune di
vigilare sull'uso che altri fanno del
potere di cui sono titolari e noi oggi
viviamo in una società dove al potere
politico e al potere esecutivo quindi
l'amministrazione dello Stato i suoi
funzionari di parlamentari i politici
eletti ad ogni livello sono sottoposti a
una possiamo dire attento pressante
Vaglio critico non gliene per non gliene
perdoniamo più una Sono anni che gli
facciamo addirittura conti in tasca e
proviamo a misurare il livello di
performance No con il valore della loro
prestazione
bene Spesso non non applichiamo la
stessa
la stessa attenzione critica lo stesso
stimolo critico ha un terzo potere che è
quello giudiziario che è vero non è
facile credere che
se faccio tutto quello che devo se
rispetto le mie scadenze fiscali se non
commetto non non faccio nulla che sia
contrario alla legge non avrò mai Non
sarò mai costretto a confrontarmi con la
macchina della Giustizia Questa è questo
è un ottimo un ottimo un ottimo
argomento spesso però è un rifugio
debole perché le questioni che
riguardano la giustizia in un modo o
nell'altro prima o poi prima o poi
investiranno
investiranno tutti noi
investono tutti noi perché se ci pensate
Non c'è niente di più politico del modo
in cui
Il cittadino
si trova davanti alla legge viene
giudicato e viene trattato nel corso del
giudizio il modo in cui si decide di
privarlo della Libertà personale
il punto dove voglio arrivare il punto
dove voglio arrivare è questo non c'è
niente di
di più entusiasmante dicevo della
ricerca dell'equilibrio però
l'equilibrio non deve essere
la convinzione di aver raggiunto la
certezza
è vero che ci incarichiamo di essere
coltivatori del dubbio e il dubbio per
me nella mia nella mia esperienza
Beh diciamo non è una fonte di
equilibrio Anzi anzi un'altalena
ma anche l'altalena l'oscillazione del
grave che è appeso diciamo a un asse è
alla ricerca di un equilibrio Quindi
qual è la il miglior modo al quale sono
giunto per definire Qual è un'idea di
equilibrio dell'informazione mi è venuta
in mente una forma geometrica ho
preferito non non avvalermi di slide
però qualcuno di voi sicuramente saprà a
cosa mi riferisco adesso che lo nomino
c'è una forma geometrica molto
particolare si chiama gombok e lo sto
pronunciando nel modo più semplice che
non è quello giusto è una è diventato un
costoso soprammobile perché la sua
realizzazione prevede una serie di
processi che è molto complessi il
gongbok è questa forma geometrica
veramente buffa che ha un solo punto di
equilibrio stabile un solo punto di
equilibrio instabile roba per nerd per i
nerd della fisica
la cosa interessante però è che questo
questo oggetto può muoversi se
sollecitato a una spinta oppure se
appoggiato nell'unico punto di
equilibrio instabile cercherà da solo di
equilibrarsi bene se voi immaginate
qualunque tentativo di raccontare una
storia e io sono ossessionato da Alcune
storie
l'ossessione è equilibrio no
Assolutamente no è roba da squilibrati
l'ossessione no ci viene detto questo se
vediamo se un nostro amico La nostra
fidanzata ci vede troppo troppo presi da
qualcosa bene È attraverso il
disequilibrio che io nella mia
esperienza vengo spinto a interessarmi
di storie che sono che sembrano anche
per me stesso chiuse e definite ed è
e mi accorgo che è necessario rotolare
un po' Come fa il Gobbo
l'altra caratteristica di questa forma
geometrica come vi dicevo molto buffa e
di avere molte facce alcune riescono a
essere raggiunte correttamente dalla
luce altre rimangono in ombra Ecco fare
il giro attorno al gombock che poi in
qualche modo la complessità della della
realtà che viviamo è è la sfida più
grande che chiunque fa il mio mestiere
dovrebbe non dovrebbe avere paura di
affrontare
Le Iene è un programma che va in onda da
25 26 27 anni dal 1997 ed è un programma
molto molto controverso
raccoglie ancora molti consensi da una
parte raccoglie ancora molte critiche Ho
provato anche a trovare a trovare la
ragione profonda del suo essere in parte
disturbante
mi accorgo che il motivo principale
potrebbe essere il fatto che all'interno
della tv italiana che è una TV tra
virgolette vecchia perché il l'età media
in Italia continua a crescere No
ad avere l'età di riferimento più
giovane
si parla molto di quello che riusciamo a
mandare in onda nella TV generalista una
TV generalista sempre più diluita
immaginate che in dieci anni il pubblico
televisivo classico e diminuito di 2
milioni e 500 mila persone circa perché
oggi ognuno si fa la propria televisione
sceglie cosa guardare a che ora
guardarlo
E invece la televisione di una volta era
qualcosa davanti alla quale ci si
riuniva e poi la si commentava
Addirittura Io sono nato in un'epoca
durante la quale ci si chiamava il
telefono fisso per dire al compagno di
scuola metti su metti sul 3 Guarda cosa
c'è in onda adesso
e il fatto che raggiungiamo le fasce del
pubblico più giovani consente ai
contenuti che vengono veicolati dalla
trasmissione di
penetrare un livello del dibattito che è
quello tra le persone che hanno meno di
30 anni che è la vera forza trainante
del programma ed è la capacità di mutare
un altro equilibrio
un'ingiustizia
un'ingiustizia è qualcosa che ha
raggiunto un equilibrio il più delle
volte e ci sembra impossibile da
metterlo da mettere in discussione quel
tipo di equilibrio bene il primo passo
per cambiare qualcosa è che più persone
la guardino quella cosa non esiste
cambiamento nella realtà che non passi
attraverso un numero crescente maggiore
di persone che vengono messe davanti a
quella situazione di ingiustizia
mostrandovi quell'equilibrio perché è un
equilibrio
l'indagine che viene chiusa
frettolosamente che quindi
non ha dato sufficienti risposte alle
vittime presunte vittime di un reato è
un equilibrio
è un equilibrio stabile
l'errore giudiziario in Italia decido
solo i dati dell'annuario statistico
della cassazione penale c'è una media
che oscilla tra anche la l'oscillazione
tra i 20 e i 27 processi penali che
vengono sottoposti a revisione con
l'annullamento senza rinvio con
l'annullamento con rinvio della condanna
Ok
quindi dietro un errore giudiziario c'è
un equilibrio ed è un equilibrio che ci
dovremmo sempre incaricare di mutare
dietro a una giustizia che non è
riuscita a soddisfare le aspettative
delle vittime cioè la necessità che
siamo in tanti a
osservare quello che è successo a
prendere
a prendere atto che l'equilibrio in quel
caso mantiene
una situazione che vogliamo cambiare
il motivo per cui sono stato molto
contento di condividere con voi la mia
esperienza e che
la ricerca dell'equilibrio nel
raccontare le storie e quindi mettersi
in mezzo già scegliere una posizione
scomoda per definizione il media stare
tra la realtà
E chi il racconto di quella realtà deve
ricevere comporta tutta una serie di di
squilibri nella vita di chi fa questo
mestiere Io
mangio male
dormo con orari diciamo non sempre
equilibrati
ho dovuto fare ricorso faccio ricorso al
supporto psicologico dello specialista
nel migliorare il mio rapporto col cibo
e
come vi dicevo prima sono ossessionato
dalle storie che racconto le storie che
racconti nelle quali cerchi attraverso
le quali cerchi di offrire un racconto
che è vero che sia più largo possibile
che faccia propria anche le affermazioni
contrarie le idee contrarie a quelle da
cui scaturisce il tuo racconto
immaginatevi immaginatevi il caso
classico Voi dite che è un fatto si è
svolto in un certo modo quello il vostro
equilibrio e dovrete anche raccogliere
la tesi contraria Ovviamente non sto più
parlando del tema scientifico dove non
c'è discussione
l'affermazione contraria è vero fa
perdere l'equilibrio
Come si mantiene l'equilibrio quando si
è portatori di una idea che è
contrastata anche in modo rumoroso
una delle Secondo me più grandi sfide
dei giovani
giornalisti o aspiranti tali è quella di
non perdere il proprio equilibrio
interiore il che significa avere piena
consapevolezza di ciò che si sta
raccontando delle implicazioni che
questo ha
ma soprattutto compiere un passaggio in
più nello studio della materia studiare
più a fondo studiare più a fondo tutte
le idee e tutti gli aspetti che mettono
in discussione la nostra tesi di
partenza se abbiamo una tesi di partenza
che come sapete è un linguaggio è un
linguaggio giornalistico il giornalismo
attesi è una forma
Sicuramente non deprecabile può piacere
o non piacere e poi la forza di quel
tipo di linguaggio si esprime nel
consenso del pubblico Nel nostro caso mi
riferisco alla mia esperienza alla mia
esperienza alle Iene abbiamo avuto o
sempre potuto avere una grandissima
libertà che è quella di cambiare in
corso d'opera il servizio che stavo
realizzando
perché l'idea di partenza è necessaria
l'idea di partenza
nella nel racconto attesi è molto chiara
è molto chiaro il risultato finale
vi faccio un esempio classico e non
entrerò qui nel merito proprio perché
voglio parlare di equilibrio e voglio
farvi capire quali sono i fattori che
l'equilibrio lo spostano e quali sono i
fattori che lo consolidano quelli che mi
aiutano a mettere in discussione
l'equilibrio degli altri è il mio
su un'idea la differenza Quindi abbiamo
detto nella quando uno ha la fortuna di
poter cambiare
la costruzione del racconto in corso
d'opera ha Chiaro come inizia non sa
dove va a finire nel caso del
giornalismo attesi tu più o meno sai
come inizia Ma hai ben chiara la
destinazione è un viaggio vincolato
farai di tutto per fare la strada che ti
sei prefigurato
ed è in qualche modo una ricerca
dell'equilibrio più facile è un po'
viaggiare in autostrada
le uniche soste sono l'autogrill e il
casello nel caso di della possibilità
che tu possa cambiare nel corso del tuo
cammino
l'itinerario vi costringerà a seguire
una strada sterrata probabilmente vi
farà bucare una gomma probabilmente
richiederà molto più tempo del viaggio
che è avreste inevitabilmente percorso
seguendo l'autostrada questo per dirvi
mi sono occupato di un'inchiesta in
cinque anni lunga 5 anni e soprattutto
non ancora non ancora terminata
perché noi abbiamo messo in discussione
il percorso dell'autostrada il percorso
comodo e
ci siamo sentiti dire anche qui una
difesa dell'equilibrio attenti Questo è
un passaggio importante le sentenze si
rispettano Non si commentano è una frase
che personalmente trovo Non solo
sbagliata ma
pericolosa pericolosa perché
atrofizza il muscolo della curiosità
atrofizza il muscolo dello stupore
indebolisce la qualità della democrazia
nella quale viviamo noi rispettiamo le
sentenze perché le seguiamo
nessuno vuole andare fuori da un
Penitenziario quando ritiene che tizio o
Caio stiano ingiustamente scontando una
pena per
strappare via i cancelli e le sbarre
dalle Celle No questo nomai ma abbiamo
invece rispetto della della Costituzione
Soprattutto la nostra la Costituzione la
Repubblica due articoli l'articolo 24 e
l'articolo 25
lo Stato La Repubblica Trova tutti i
medi per riparare tutti i rimedi utili
per riparare l'errore giudiziario lo
facciamo
attirando Su di noi
le spinte di chi parte da una posizione
comoda
Qual è la posizione comoda
l'equilibrio consolidato e su cui c'è
stato il consenso è stata placata
l'ansia di avere un responsabile è stata
soddisfatta la nostra sede di giustizia
tutte le volte in cui questo schema
viene in qualche modo ribaltato e si
mette la il pubblico lo spettatore il
lettore di fronte all'ipotesi che non
sia quello il punto finale il vero punto
di equilibrio Ma che quella quel
risultato possa essere scardinato e
sgretolato beh
le conseguenze Non sono sempre piacevoli
e il mio consiglio che poi è il
la sostanza di questo intervento e della
mia ultima riflessione è questa non
fatevi
squilibrare da chi dice che vi state
sbagliando ascoltate ogni parola di chi
dice che vi state sbagliando
confrontatela con la realtà che viene
dagli elementi di cui siete in possesso
e non date per scontato che chi va nella
direzione opposta alla vostra si stia
sbagliando perché potrebbe essere
illuminante anche l'elemento portato da
chi vi dice che si sbaglia e a quel
punto sì che sarete sulla strada di un
equilibrio un equilibrio Che cos'è che
non è sicuramente
indifferenza non è sicuramente
equidistanza tra il vero e ciò che è
vero non è
non sarà la verità non sarà la verità ma
non vi distoglierà mai da dal sentiero
per provare a raggiungerla
tentare di intraprendere un percorso che
vi porti alla verità Questo è un
insegnamento utile per i giovani
giornalisti aspiranti tali è un modo
equilibrato di procedere l'equilibrio
non sarà mai nella bilanciare
l'informazione con le conseguenze
dell'informazione una destinazione ma
potrebbe essere la vostra bussola
Grazie